the U.S has deployed supersonic
supersonic bombers and fighter jets in
response to the recent increase in
hostility and missile tests carried out
by North Korea South Korea's Joint
Chiefs of Staff showed the b-1b bombers
conducting joint aerial drills with
other South Korean and U.S warplanes so
let's speak to retired Air Vice Marshall
Sean Bell he is here with us he knows a
bit about aerial drills don't you there
are the planes those are the bombers are
they two b-1b bombers on the right hand
side there's the f-35s uh South Koreans
and on the left wing the ones closest to
us the f-16s the Americans it's worth
providing a bit of context here I think
um for for viewers Korea was first
um annexed by Japan in 1910 and in 1945
at the end of the second world war
um the former Soviet Union America cut
it in two it was administered to the
north by former Soviet Union China for
the South by America and its allies and
became a bit of the front line in a cold
war in 1950
um the the Soviet Union party weapons
into North Korea they attacked South
Korea America stepped in to help and
ensured the survival of South Korea and
at the end of that war they agreed to
step back to the original timelines but
the U.S has remained committed to South
Korean security ever since but in the
years since the decades since North
Korea has become increasingly isolated
and it spent more and more of its money
on missiles and weapons particularly
trying to Source nuclear weapons okay so
now why do we have these drills taking
place what is the background to that in
the the near pasture was it yeah so on
Friday
um North Korea launched its latest
nuclear rocket attack ballistic missile
test why this is important the range of
this particular missile could reach the
continental United States of America and
it has the potential to carrying
multiple Warheads as well these missiles
go a long way and even a test missile it
went up over 3 700 miles and it goes
right here about 620 miles landed in the
Sea of Japan over to our rights but it's
also of interest that all career has
been potentially readying itself for
another nuclear test it hasn't done one
of these for five years yet now the U.S
routinely conducts these joint military
operations with their South Korean
colleagues but of course every time that
happens North Korea feels threatened and
it responds accordingly as soon as it
responds the U.S has to escalate
um now the uh it's worth remembering the
U.S military is committed to freedom of
Passage across the whole area and you'll
recall there's
um a down to the South there's Taiwan
there's also South Korea and of course
there's the military Naval Base at
Okinawa uh down to the South there which
the US holds which is 26
000 troops there just by way of context
when I was commanding a royal Air Force
military base only had two thousand so
it's a vast military presence down there
in the South there's
um the testing that they do we often
hear oh it crashed off this off in the
Sea of Japan how do they know how far it
can go they're testing to see how far it
can go does it go a little bit further
every test or how does that work well
the problem is with these things is the
further they go the more unpredictable
but it is where it's going to land so
they only put enough fuel in it and
guide it to land somewhere in
international waters which is why
they're doing this test now
interestingly see why Kim Young is doing
these tests he normally does it for
three reasons one of which is to
actually test and develop his weapons
second is to send a really powerful
message to International Community
particularly the United States but also
domestically to show how what a great
and powerful leader he is interestingly
let's look back to the Ukraine conflict
Ukraine used to be the third largest
nuclear power in in the world but
exceeded those weapons back in the early
1990s would Russia invaded Ukraine had
it still got nuclear weapons and that
message I think is really powerful
because for North Korea that feels
paranoid about its own security it needs
to get a nuclear the nuclear capability
with the one ultimate deterrent and
secure its uh attack as cure its
position but it's a dangerous country
it's an unstable country from West's
perspective the West has put a load of
sanctions on North Korea over the years
that has massively impacted its economy
has not stopped at developing weapons
what I think we can see in the near term
is a continued effort by North Korea to
develop nuclear weapons it wants it
knows it has to negotiate its way out of
these uh and but in the near term we're
going to expect continued escalation and
the risk of miscalculation